[музика]
компетентність і включає себе не лиж з
знання а крем знань у мене мета
цінності ставлення які ви означає здати
не слюдяні успішного вирішу в цій же
темі проблеми права проводити
професії ну то подалі початкову
діяльність йєті компот індустрія київ
а нинішня школа на мага це формувати
і у наших дітей сема ти ми точно
competed низ computed несу природний
чиїх науках інформативно цифра в
знання видно та мови державну йому ви
українську йому ви і
іноземних мох сьогоднішня школа
прогнути роботи allure про бойця зовсім
визнай спасибі на дроти шкода в
україні ми con статуї модний рівний
доступ даяки з але його свити
червона пошитий силан позову компетентно стояки
в загалини формується в школі а по ви
за крима грому я низько компетентність ми
по виніс форму вати вид під видаль нова
громадини і на патріота так само
and nice наприклад соціально як людей на
у мить розуму не kuwait з нашими людьми так
сама компетентність екологічно
я за вас друк з успіху їдальню
розвитку
так само компетентність я кас прямого
на на рожевий струм pride наступниця і
фінансову грамотність устя вся низько
компетентностей яга 1 травня виду кидайся
в нову оного але ми разом про почет його з
жахливими методик навчання у новій
українській школі
про крем з їх компетентністю є вміння
на вишці їх часто називають лікарем і
новачками які нас кріс але mavic pro низу
у цьому процес навчання
щоб дитинка мало і всієї кривої
після забудь а повне за хворі середні
Свити сам видати не скрипковому якщо ти
здати їх but it злодій чим креативним
здати низ аргументом вона захищає і
владно позицію працювати в команді
матрос вийнятий емоційний інтелект цпш
необхідний шкірний дитину для успішної
самореалізації та переплетення
компетентностей
цих новачок і вміння краз тварюки та
ту канву я до винна в приємному розвитку
шкірні дитинки
[музика]